est ce que pour vous le couple idéal
c'est se laisser la possibilité d'aller
voir ailleurs
alors oui on a eu en plus d'un grand
débat dans btp vendredi oui non j'aime
bien ce nom jamais de la vie
à partir du moment où on va voir
ailleurs il ya plus de couple d'accord
c'est fini c'est mort c'est enterrer ses
incinérés on en parle plus on peut même
si on va juste en face pour manger une
boulette comme ça dérape juste ouvert on
est en tajine comme ça ajoute on nonm
hashtag tajine non non vous auriez moi
je pense que quand on est follement
amoureux ouais on ne voit qu'une
personne ou le dur pour cette personne
on a pensé le monde l'appréhension du
monde n'est que pour cette personne
c'est une focalisation une
cristallisation absolue donc les autres
n'existent ne cite pas nicolas si la
convergence du des des fantasmes sexuels
dans un couple idéal faut que l'histoire
parfaite
c'était en fait on est excité par la
même chose quand il peut pas y avoir
d'infidélité dans le sens où figure et
présente des limites données de chaque
sa part et que ce qui est au centre
suffit à l'épanouissement des deux est
longue il n'y aurait pas de question
d'aller voir ailleurs
c'est en fait si on est dans les mêmes
là on n'est pas frustré en tant que
l'excellence et la fantasmagorie
inconsciente c'est le noyau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très important dans l'audace et de
la convergence des fantasmes si ces
vidéos ont les mêmes fantasmes et que ça
leur convient ils peuvent rester à vie
ensemble assez ça allait pas avoir les
mêmes pentes aliments alors vous vous
êtes vous pouvez aller voir ailleurs
mais non mais pardon c'est être à vue
c'est pas les brailleurs entendu ça qui
va faire les courses et le g20 et non
pas du tout c'est ce que l'on croise i5
à la réalité la réalité c'est que si
vous ne déménagerait du soufisme la
corde si vous n'y décorrélée pas
justement le visitent donc cesser ses
vannes 22 ans 15 cm 2 parties du corps
si vous le décor n'est pas le sexe de
l'amour
forcément ça crée frustration qui crée
culpabilité qui crée colère et s'est
ancré séparation ces énoncés par m
nous vous ferons tous car vous êtes moi
je pense le contraire et je suis sûr que
c'est parce que justement tu fais ça et
que tu as cette façon de penser là que
tu n'as pas encore trouvé une bonne âme
soeur parce que je suis d alors on me
dit qu'il ya quelqu'un qui m'envoient
par twitter qui me dit moi je suis pour
l'instant d'élite et voilà renforce mon
cours alamo couple ces familles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
hashtag gp soho matignon merci vous non
mais moi c'est pour moi c'est impossible
quand on aime on ne se permet même pas à
penser à quelqu'un d'autre en fait c'est
moi une personne fidèle qui ne soit pas
frustré une seule mais sa grande soeur
et nous acquittant 10 rebonds sont fous
toi aussi fais quoi que nous vaut
quelques est en fait la réalité jean
crépu problème aussi ses possessions moi
c'est sa lame le port le futur le
présent c'est pas les plaies bien voilà
bien sûr pas évidemment la jalousie
quand on aime passionnément ça vient
très vite même un échange de regards
peut déclencher des attaques un smack
c'est un échange de regards
moi j'ai vu en fidèle sénat images où je
la vois comme ça
elle regarde une autre écoute comme un
cinéma regarde que de la bouffe je suis
parti en délire cap et umag risque un
pays sans rêver c'était un truc de désir
de composer
bon moi j'ai jamais ça va quoi ne désire
plus se composait et ben c'est très bien
comme ça moi je m'en foutais maintenant
je suis là je dis ça pour francesca
quand elle va ou posséder parce qu'elle
vous aimera plus est ce que pour vous le
couple idéal s'être collé à son conjoint
24 urban a dream
oui oui collé serré
areola la wii mais ne pas laisser ainsi
mettre des stars alors dû revoir tout ça
je ne sais pas me mettre l'espace entre
pas tout et vous pas j'essaye mais elle
vaut pas le coup rennes ce qu'il faut
faire ce couple ne tiendra pas à vous
vous faites quoi
le contraire de ce qu'il veut faire être
collés l'un à l'autre tout le temps ça
c'est le début de l' esclavage vous êtes
paul et alain ah mais non on a nos
moments communs
c'est quoi les moments comment le lit de
badminton le ses amis s'étaient mariés
ça compte a pas d'un côté oui croyez que
mémé c'est m accompagner partout c'est
vite dit fait comprendre que ça apparaît
que voulez vous accompagner partout
disent oui jouer partout ah ouais c'est
fou alors quoi le proverbe qui dit si tu
veux garder un homme fait dû comprendre
tous les jours qu'il peut partir
absolument
on a mûri à toutes les ruses sont
permises sur et toutes les ambiguïtés
sont permises
évidemment et on ne sort de la salle des
cris c'est vrai sur la réelle de fox
ariel de fort bonne alors oui je me suis
partant quand vous passez sasson voulons
financer l'installation sans rigoler on
n'en peut plus l'amour c'est comme une
cigarette lui barton s'est pas non plus
des normes dissertation oui ça va ça va
c'est bon et que carlos diegues bien
vous est-ce qu'il faut être mollet
qu'est ce qui fait de colle à son mec 24
24 ou non je pense pas non le paraguay
impossible déjà je pense que c'est mieux
c'est vrai il va être content est ce que
pour vous le couple idéal doit forcément
avoir les mêmes goûts est-ce que voilà
autour de la table
quel et les quels sont les deux choses
vraiment pour faire le port est dans un
couple il ya les moeurs principe pas
goût d'accord alors exemple ça serait
quoi vous benhaim il faut partager le
sens de l'humour d'abord le même sens de
l'humour que les mêmes mots font rire
c'est très important versé et et
s'émerveiller des mêmes choses à méroé
benhaim chien qui fait vous bernard
montiel c est de bronze et le goût de
l'aventuré de la découverte du voyage
ouais faut lui vaut rien [ __ ] quoi
voilà un courriel vous c'est quoi ce que
ça fait 25 ans que vous êtes avec le
même mot oui c'est vrai c'est beau le
bénisse non franchement etc et c'est
quoi c'est quoi les deux les deux choses
eh bien je crois un principe
d'admiration et rsa et puis un défi et
le et l'idée que rien n'est jamais
acquis jamais at il jamais acquis jamais
acquis d'autant que le monde mais on va
chez vous donner la parole merci alors
on a déjà bien changé de besoin
vous allez me faire des excuses réponse
il débute c'est à la mode est donc ouais
c'est le s le cfj complicité fidélité
indépendance
ah ouais c'est pas vrai j'ai choisi
l'indépendance en fait vous et gerald
une seule et même valeur
incontestablement et le sexe
malheureusement je préfère que sur les
valeurs vous non miscibles on va vous
dire plaisir à l'autre bonjour chercher
à dijon quoi au canada et audi sportive
le l'autre pourraient désirer
d'accord elle est dans ce sens là
d'accord vous mais nous savions croit
toujours bien se connaître de beaux de
40 ans c'est pas vrai vous vouliez nous
faire faire avec mon mari les amours
finalement c'était trop tard on l'a pas
fait et un jour au restaurant s'est dit
tiens si on se pose et les kenyans
qu'andré de nous poser vous même si
jusqu'au dessert préféré c'est différent
des personnes si comme l'a dit non mais
les deux les deux trucs on est on est où
les deux truc c'est les valeurs temps a
dit le sexe et il faut que tu te plantes
si t'as pas les mêmes idées politiques
avec le temps ouais c'est pas vrai
regardez marielle ils n'ont pas les
mêmes besoins des principes sur les
bonnes idées sur rien et ce n'est pas
jean pêche pas de pad à côté oui parce
qu'à deux choses il faut se laisser
aimer il faut que la personne en face
classé mais et laisser tomber sa fierté
ouais c'est vrai comme vous c'est quoi
vous à boeing peut atterrir avec un seul
réacteur
il en faut deux pour voler les deux
boeing du recteur c'est le sexe et le
deuxième fois qu'on disait
conneries de ce côté là parce qu'encore
une fois ce service vous êtes chez vous
je suis celui qui sait les choses voilà
si si je veux dire ce soir d'une
histoire de deux enquêtes est très
complet alors dos avec les nerfs de sexe
etc et la deuxième chose c'est
l'éducation quoi qu'on dise si on ne
vient pas du même milieu social que
l'autre en fait c'est un enfant cela
bouleverse en face à un avocat on a de
même et vous et vous à moi j'ai besoin
d'admirer la personne
j'ai besoin de la sentir plus haute que
moi et aussi j'ai mal à redorer vous
rendez vous avec ak rigoler quoi vous
donner
mais la raison j'ai besoin que qu'il
m'aime - comme moi je laime non c'est un
challenge au jour le jour sérieux allen
jean fabre et ses satellites
ouais moi les mois les les dévoués mais
qu'au niveau sunu super tôt
donc c'est le chef qu'est ce qui t'a
fait prouve d'éprouver sentiment pas le
simple appât secret flag